can you answer these three questions
first we need to understand what a
parallelogram is a parallelogram is a
quadrilateral with its opposite sides
parallel and equal
what is a rhombus
a rhombus is a quadrilateral with its
opposite sides parallel and all four
sides equal to each other
now if you observe carefully this
fulfills all the conditions of a
parallelogram hence a rhombus is a
special case of a parallelogram
and what's a rectangle
a rectangle is a quadrilateral with
opposite sides parallel and equal
and there is one more condition that
says all four angles must be equal to 90
degrees
now if you observe a rectangle is also
one of the special cases of a
parallelogram
what's a square then a square is a
quadrilateral with opposite sides
parallel and equal and all its angles
are equal to 90 degrees with all equal
sides
and you'll notice that a square is a
special case of a rectangle a rhombus
and a parallelogram
so the answer to these three questions
is yes